straight straight to the point so um
ladies and gents
um we're going to start off with an
article from the guardian okay I'm gonna
read this article and it says this the
office for National statistics shows
that women not living in a couple who
have never been married is rising in
every angrage under under 70. in the in
in the decade and a half between
2002 sorry to 2018 the figure for those
age 40 to 70 year olds by half a million
the percentage of never married
Singletons in their 40s doubled there is
no avoiding that our romantic
opportunities have dwindled as the poor
of age-appropriate men has been emptied
this is what a woman's now saying
annually we manage a small smattering
updates between us most of us have grown
wary of online dating which requires you
to treat it as an all-consuming hobby or
a part-time job we are tired of Tinder
bored of bumble I have been ejected by
eHarmony which I last time last time I
logged on you told me I could they could
not find me a single match wow they
couldn't find her a single match what a
lady in the guardian said she would they
were interviewing her I wonder what she
looks like yeah how much she weigh she's
probably a whale yeah she's probably a
whale
so ladies what do we think what do we
think of the Dayton scene right now and
our modern women becoming more lonely
okay I was in a five-year relationship
which means I was 23 when I got into
when I was 28 when I came out I'm not
29. when I came out I decided to join
hinge and Tinder because I was dealing
with 24 25 year old men and now I'm
dealing with men that plus 30 plus so I
want to know what the new kind of pool
of dating feels like and to be honest
it's not good I feel like people are too
focus on the The Superficial it doesn't
go deep enough and that's why people
don't trust each other it's not just
because women are turning bad it goes
both ways so yeah it's messed up right
now for real I agree with that
yeah I've never been to any uh dating
sites and everything and every time I
date someone I have to meet them face to
face like you know from friends to
friends and like All My Exes I never
found them like any social media or um
you know I mean probably yeah not social
media but it's more likely like I've met
them in real life instead of actually
being on a dating app and everything our
stories are quite similar mandanova so I
was also in a relationship for five
years and I've never been the same as
Angel I've never been on a dating
website and when that relationship ended
I didn't think to go straight to a
dating website I just stepped outside I
did it for research purposes by the way
do you think I have problems finding a
man
is long
come on let's just weigh in okay
okay it's very um
we live in a world with social media and
we live in a world with a lot of
distraction and I think people are under
the illusion that people are replaceable
and are very much addicted to the
dopamine hit of meeting someone new and
the infatuation but the minute it gets
difficult oh well there's someone I can
swipe on Tinder and they'd want to go
out with me kind of thing and I think
also too in in in society I think men
have they know what women want they know
what women need and I don't think it's
the other way around
I would agree with that so you would say
that men know what women want but women
don't know what men want yeah
yeah
um you are perfect just the way you are
and you don't need to settle for anyone
less than you deserve and so I think and
so I think it leads people astray and
the question is what do you deserve you
deserve what you get and that's
something we don't tell women I think I
do you deserve it I think you deserve
like
someone on your level and I think I
think women with social media and stuff
if you if you like post a picture with
your butt out or even if you just post a
Photoshop photo or just a photo of
yourself and your Instagram is public
you can get thousands sorry I mean I
mean get like commitment wise oh like so
I'm saying like girls deserve what they
can get commitment wise but if I say I
deserve to be a millionaire and I don't
get millionaire outcomes that I probably
don't deserve to be a millionaire yeah
what that's too far as well to be able
to oh yeah this is that much but like I
feel like most women just want
um a lot of respect as well from their
partner more like and you know get um
you know gestures and all these romantic
things when you're in a relationship
what I'm talking about and I feel like
nowadays it's really hard to find
a man that would do that because of how
the world is at the moment you know our
generation that's just you know as what
you said social media and all these
things it just distract a lot of man
fully because they like a lot of men
follow women on Instagram because
obviously they find these females
attractive and all these things and that
kind of messes up how they think about
females too so when they're trying to
um when they Chana uh I don't know if a
girl if they're dating are females if
they're dating a girl it's really hard
for them to like focus on that one
person because there's so many things on
social media that's only I would say
that's only a small percentage of men
because most men don't have the options
to focus on other girls
so like like on um dating apps women
only swipe right five percent of the
time where men swipe right fifty percent
of the time
and like one one out of one out of three
minutes one on one out of three men are
either virgins or haven't had sex in the
past year yeah so so those you're saying
like those guys like they're not you
would be the center of their world but
we don't want those guys like for
example if you want a guy that's over
six foot you know I'm looking at my tall
you know yeah which same but but that's
only 15 of men and if you want to be
good looking cut that in half if you
want to make money cut that in half if
you want and if you want if you want
them to have a similar personality like
charismatic cut that in half so that's
it's like two percent of guys we're all
fighting over so then do you see why do
you see why I'm asking the question do
modern women want cats or dogs because
you're gonna be lonely because if you if
you are fighting in a pool of men
that only a certain amount there's only
a certain amount of those top tier men
that women want but 80 of women
generally list 20 of men when they ask
for their ideal men right so if there's
20 of men who have an 80 pool of women
to choose from that will leave at least
what 60 of women without a partner
however those women continue to fight
for that top 20 man and that's one of
the reasons why a lot of women say men
are trash men are dogs men are this
because they are fighting for the same
men well and half of those guys don't
commit to anyone why would you why why
would you if you have that many options
like Drake was Drake gonna get a wife no
but I think it goes back to what you
were saying about how do women even know
what they want anyway in the first no no
that's not what I said I said do women
know what men want okay oh we want to
know that's a good question because it's
a job make sure you
catch resources
so that you can find
looking woman or best woman you can but
like a lot of women don't know what
genuinely satisfies a man I know in my
experience in the past I just thought
like I was told to date who I want to be
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible